who studied these quantitative syllabi
theorems
these were then
quantitatively improved in joint work
with wheel and vegasin
and they are very intimately connected
to the question of two query locally
collectible codes of the reals
in joint work with albert eyes and we're
in avi we also study approximate or
stable sylvester galley-like theorems
and i'll mention this and much of the
talk i'll be talking about a very recent
work with dwarian wigerson
on some combination of high dimensional
and quantitative sylvester galley
theorems which are connected to three
query locally collectible codes over the
rails and that that would be the
significant bulk of the dog so here's
the plan
in the first half i'll tell you about
all these extensions of the sylvester
like theorems which are known
and in the second half i'll tell you
what the connection to locally
collectible codes is and then this new
lower bound for three query locally
collectible codes over the reals which
we get by studying the three query
version of the sylvester gala theorem
okay so first let me so
the sylvester gulai theorem i talked
about
the proof was very specific to the real
numbers we use a lot of properties of
the real numbers to prove the theorem
for instance the notion of distance
between the point and the line
also the fact that two of the points
were in the same side of the foot of the
perpendicular so the ordering of the
real numbers was very important
and
it turns out that the vestige theorem is
in fact not true over the complex
numbers
so there is a configuration of points in
the two-dimensional complex plane
where where the points are not collinear
and
uh
the line through every the complex line
through every pair of points passes
through the third point
so it turns out to be not true but it
was shown by kelly
that
you can't have such configurations in
three-dimensional complex plane so if
you have a finite set of points in some
complex space
where the line through every pair of
points passes through the third
then these must be contained within a
two dimensional plane you can't have
higher dimensional configurations
and the original proof was fairly
complicated
in 2006 the first elementary proof of
this result was given
and
in some of the what i'm going to be
talking about later we get it the tools
are we develop will give a new proof
of this result using some basic linear
algebra
so that's one kind of
that's sylvester gala theorem over the
complexes
here is another very interesting uh
version of this
sylvester gala theorem the quantitative
syllabus theorem
where we don't ask that for every pair
of points
the line through them passes through the
third but for many pair of pairs of
points you have the property that the
line through them pass it through a
third point
can you then say anything about the
structure of the points okay so
so here is the lcr configuration of
points is a delta silver segali
configuration
if for every point
there are many other points so delta
fraction of other points
so that the line through those pair of
points passes through a third point
so for instance a grid
is i think a one-fourth sylvester i
configuration
so for every pair of points there are
many other points
which says that the line through them
will pass through a third point
and so this was the setting which was
studied in this the work by barack v
vignessen and yahudayof
and using this was a very beautiful
result very beautiful techniques and
i'll
talk a little bit about this result what
they showed was
if you take any delta sylvester galley
configuration in some euclidean space
the only way such a configuration can
exist is that the dimension is bounded
it's at most some constant depending
only on delta it's order of one over
delta square
and then in joint work with wheel and
victim we
analyzed their
proof more carefully and we were able to
show that in fact the dimension is at
most order one over delta
and this bound is tight
okay so for instance if you take one
over delta skew lines each containing
delta endpoints then it would form a
delta silver stegali configuration in
one over delta dimensions
so if we almost fully understand how
such configurations the
the parameters for such configurations
okay so let me say a few words about the
proof of this result uh because many of
the other sylvester gulli like theorems
even the proof even the sylvester
goliath for the complexes etc
follows basically this outline of proof
the proofs of these incidence theorems
is going to follow from something called
the rank bounds for design matrices so
let me tell you what the connection is
and i'm just going to give you a very
high level
outline of proof and not go into details
okay so suppose you have a bunch of
vectors v one through v n in some
complex space
and you have it's a delta synthesize
configuration so you have a whole bunch
of collinear triples within your set of
points so for every collinear for for
every collinear triple these three
points are going to be linearly
dependent so there's some coefficients
alpha
so for every viv jvk
there'll be some coefficients alpha
alpha j alpha k so that the
corresponding linear combination is 0.
and you can use all these dependent
triples
to
construct these two matrices v and a v
is the matrix where you just put all the
vectors v i as the rows of the matrix
and a is a matrix where you put for the
rows of the matrix you put these
triples alpha alpha g alpha k in the ijk
location
ah
good then
it's not hard to see that if you
construct these matrices a times v
equals zero
okay so v was the
matrix of all the vectors a was the
matrix you got by just for every
choliner triple you added the
corresponding linear combination as a
row of the matrix
so we were given the set of vectors
which formed a delta silverstag
configuration we built this matrix such
that a times v0
and then
carefully understanding the matrix
a and carefully pruning it
it was observed
that this matrix is actually a design
matrix
and as i'll say what i mean by design
but this matrix was a design matrix
what the goal of the theorem was to
prove that the vectors v are low
dimensional
right so the goal was to show that the
vectors are low dimensional this is
equivalent to saying that the rank of v
is small so you want to prove the rank
of v small
what you know is a times v zero
so one way to prove that the rank of v
is small is to prove that the rank of a
must be really large
if the rank of a is really large and a
times v zero the only way it could be is
that the rank of v is small
so
so that so that was that's a proof
strategy we got this matrix a it was a
design matrix and now it just suffices
to lower bound the rank of this design
matrix so let me tell you what a design
matrix is
we say an m by n matrix is a qkt design
if
you just look at the zero non-zero
pattern of the entries of the matrix
every column has many non-zero entries
the intersection of every pair of
columns
has
a small intersection
and every row has few non-zero entries
though this this every row has few
non-zero entries is not such an
important term the more
the k and the t are really the important
parameters in the setting so every
column has many non-zeros and the
intersection of every pair of columns is
small the support of the intersection is
small that's what a design matrix is
and
the way to and the so in barrage this is
showed that
any such
qkt design matrix must have large rank
and we in and in joint work with v vegas
in we got we improved the bounds on for
the design matrices and
this bound we get here is
basically optimal
so basically every qkt design matrix so
having entries over the complex numbers
if it is a qkt design its rank needs to
be is at least so much
and in the setting where they showed up
in the sylvester configurations
q was basically a constant t was
basically a constant and k was
order n
so this
term
ended up being a constant
so the rank of the design matrix was
basically full rank it was n minus a
constant which tells you that the
corresponding vector matrix v the
syllabus the vectors of the sylvester
like configuration had to be in constant
dimensions
so that's so that's how it worked i
won't tell you what goes in the how the
these rank bounds for design matrices
are proved but the main idea was some
notion of matrix scaling which is
which was a very very nice idea and very
beautifully used
so some things to note about the rank
bounds
these hold for any field of
characteristic 0
or very large characteristic but they
are not true over small finite fields so
their counter examples to this result
and yeah just this rank bound result
this statement about the rank bound
itself is enough to imply the sylvester
glycerin over the complex numbers so it
gives you exactly the constant 2 which
was needed for the dimension of
sylvester light configurations over the
complexes
because let me tell you another so that
was the
the quantitative silverlight theorem
let me tell you another variation which
you can ask of the sylvester galley
theorem which is the stable version of
the theorem
so you have a bunch of points in
euclidean space
and suppose you know that you for every
pair of points
the line through that pair almost passes
through a third point
so these points are not exactly
collinear but approximately equilibrium
what can you say about this
configuration of points
where every pair of
the line through every pair is
approximately passing through the third
so natural thing to hope for in this
case would be to say
the points are not you can't
perhaps hope to say that they are all in
low dimensions but you could hope
perhaps hope to to say that
they're approximately low dimensional
so the hope could be that then all these
points must be
close to linear close to lying on a line
so it turns out that this the statement
at least as i stated it is not quite
true
so it's not true that so there are there
is a configuration of points
spanning
robustly spanning a high dimensional
space so that for every pair of points
if you draw the line through them
it will be that line will be epsilon
close to a third point you can actually
find such a configuration which is high
dimensional so this stable syllabus the
goliath theorem as is is not true to
make it true perhaps more assumptions on
the set of points might be necessary
and what we showed with uh albert i and
dweer and wignerson
is that suppose you add the assumption
that the distances between pairs of
points isn't too skewed so all the
distances are bounded between one and
some parameter b
then
and and you know that for every pair of
points there's a third point which is a
pr epsilon collinear with it then the
dimen then the set of points is going to
be pretty close to uh a space of
dimension b to the sex
other examples of these that do not come
from just perturbing
genuine symmetrical examples yes so this
uh
counter example which i said
uh which i talked about where which
varies
in the balance setting uh
no i so i don't we know very very few
examples of how yeah so i don't know any
non-trivial examples it could be the
case that all such sets are in fact just
slight perturbations of genuine
absolutely yes
so you so this this this bound we show
is actually probably far from tight and
perhaps you can put much milder
restrictions on the set of points and
conclude truly that the only way you can
derive is is this is from genuine
sylvester i configurations and we don't
know how to show this
and i think it will be very very
interesting to show such a result and
these results are also very closely
connected to other questions in
combinatorics which i don't want to talk
about but i think that's a very nice
direction to pursue
epsilon prime dimension means means
so i don't remember what we showed but
epsilon prime was some function of
epsilon we asked about the definition of
this oh sorry
so all these points are epsilon prime
close to a subspace of dimension b to
the six and where the constant epsilon
prime is some function of the
of epsilon
so that's one kind of proof the way we
prove this result
at a high level follows a similar
outline to the old proof i talked about
where we have we construct this design
matrix
but now
we don't have to we don't uh
get to just lower bound the rank of the
matrix we need to robustly lower down
the rank of the matrix where we show
that the number of eigenvalues with
number of eigenvectors with small
eigenvalue
are large
yeah
so okay here's another variation of the
sylvester gala theorem which is very
interesting also
so so far we just talked about
incidences between points and lines
you can talk about incidences between
higher dimensional
planes and points
so the sylvester goliath theorem says
that
if for every pair of points the line
through them passes through the third
then the points must be low dimensional
you can ask
what if through every set of k points
the plane through them passes through a
k plus first point can you then say
something about the dimension of these
points
and such high dimensional sylvester life
films were studied a long time ago and
over the years we have pretty good
bounds
uh
we see that if you have this k
dimensional version of the sylvester
light theorem the points must be in at
most two k dimensions
the work by barak dwight vegas
so this result is
it's elementary but the proof is still
fairly complicated
the techniques introduced in
this the rank bound kind of techniques
are robust enough that they extend
to prove such results even over the
complex numbers
i know they also give quantitative
versions of these theorems over the
complex numbers but the bounds are still
far from
what we what from optimal
so that's the high dimensional sylvester
goliath theorems
there was even a colorful you can ask
colorful versions of these theorems and
this was something
we used uh to understand the structure
of arithmetic circuits this was the kind
of question which came up
where the setting was you have a finite
set of points in euclidean
space and each point was colored one of
k colors
and and if the hyperplane through every
if for every k minus one points of
different colors if you look at the
hyper plane through them and it passes
through a point of the kth color
then the points need to be low
dimensional
this was studied by edelson and kelly in
the 66 they did it for k equal to three
and we had to generalize similar results
for general k
and this showed up in arithmetic
complexity so that was again one kind of
sylvester life theorem
and
so let's i just want to mention one more
so
so ben green and terry tau very recently
studied another setting of the
quantitative syllabi theorem
where so the usual syllabi theorem the
way i said it was that if you have a set
of points spanning two-dimensional space
then you must have at least one line
which passes through two points exactly
two points
but but maybe there are many lines which
must pass
through
uh
exactly two points
and so this was conjunct this was an
open conjecture for a long time that
they must have at least n over two such
lines which passed through exactly two
points and this was fully resolved in
this recent work using some very
beautiful techniques and this work
actually fully characterized how these
configurations of points must look like
which have very few lines
ordinary lines which are lines through
exactly two points
yeah so yeah so this result is known
where for
some very large values offends and still
open for
some small finite values right
okay good so that's what i wanted to
tell you about the kinds of sylvester
gallery theorems
that we've been looking at recently
in this in the next half let me tell you
what the connection of all these
sylvester galley theorems is to locally
correctable codes
and then tell you about
three query locally collectable codes
and what we can do for it
so a locally collectible code a linear
locally collectable code is given by
some
the generator matrix
and uh you have some message m and the
encoding of the message is just m times
g so it's some
a k dimension a k symbol long message
gets stretched to some n symbol long
vector
and then some corruptions occur so some
delta fraction of the coordinates gets
adversarially corrupted
and so you rece you what is it what you
get after the corruptions is some
corrupted code word
and in the usual notion of error
correction you would want to take this
corrupted code word and recover what the
true uncorrupted messages or the true
uncorrupted code word is
in a locally correctable code
you want something much stronger you
want to recover every symbol of
the true code word by actually looking
at only very very few locations of the
corrupted code word so we will say a
locally correctable code is a q delta
locally correctable code and think of q
to be something like two or three for
now
if whenever you corrupt even grab delta
fraction of the locations of the true
code word
you can recover any
coordinate of the corrupted of the true
code word accurately with high
probability by looking at the corrupted
code word only in
queue locations we make queue something
really small
so for instance
this is the way how the decoder would
work you would feed it you would say
okay i want the i symbol of the true
code word the decoder would then just go
query the corrupted code word in some
very few locations and tell you what the
ith
code or the to the true i symbol is
and here's an observation which is a
fairly straightforward observation
so suppose you wanted the ith location
of
the code word and the decoder queried
the j and k in lth locations to tell you
what the value was at the ith location
the only way the j k and l locations can
tell you what the value of the ith
location is
is that if you look at the corresponding
columns of this generator matrix they
must be linearly dependent
so p i p j so here q is 3 in this
example so it must be that p i is in the
linear span of p j p k and p l
and in fact
since this decoder needs to be able to
give the correct answer with high
probability even if there are
corruptions the only way this is going
to happen is that not only should pi be
in the linear span of some pj pkpl but
pi will be need to be in the linear span
of many triples of columns which span it
so that in spite of corruptions the
decoder can find one which will
accurately decode to the right right
answer
so the so the geometric translation of
what it means to be a locally
collectible code is the following
so you can look at this generator matrix
and you can look at the columns of the
generator matrix and identify them as
vectors
in whatever field you're working in so
these will be n points in f to the k
and
if you wanted to decode to the ith
location you needed many of these
vectors to be linearly to linearly
decode the ith location this will
correspond to for every
point p i
there should be many disjoint q tuples
which span p i
so you'll so when q is 3 for instance
for every coordinate i you need to have
a lot of
three-dimensional planes
or you need to have a lot of
two-dimensional planes so you have a lot
of three tuples where you look at the
plane through them it must pass
through pi so you'll have all these
uh
four tuples containing uh pi which are
all linearly dependent
and this must happen for every
coordinate
so for for if so you take another
another point pj and you'll have again
many disjoint q tuples or three tuples
which span the point
okay so that's that's the equivalent
geometric uh translation
and notice that when
q
when we stop these q tuples when for q
equal to two this is exactly equivalent
to the notion of being a delta silver
estimate configuration
if for every point there were many pairs
of points which were collinear with that
point here when q is three for every
point there are many disjoint triples of
points
which
are coplanar with that point
so that's so it's uh it's exact it's a
it's like the sylvester galactic
configuration but one dimension higher
yeah so for every there we have n
different matchings of q tuples
each corresponding to which point
they're decoding
okay so locally correctable codes
have played a very central role
in theoretical computer science in
program testing the pcp theorem
ip equals p space etc so they're very
fundamental notion very well studied but
we still understand very very little
about
what locally collectable codes we can
construct and what is possible what is
not possible
so basically the only examples of
locally collectable codes we know are
the hadamard code and the readmala code
and on the lower bound side we only know
very very weak lower bounds for these
codes
and
it was shown by dwayr that even
if you want to talk about locally
collectible codes when q is something as
large as polylog q
even very weak lower bounds for these
codes would imply new lower bounds and
matrix rigidity
so they're
interesting even
from that connection
so let me tell you what we do know about
what kinds of locally collectable codes
we can construct and what lower bounds
we have
so in the setting of two query locally
collectable codes
the only example we know the only
constructions we know are the hadamard
code
and actually we understand two query
locally collectible codes pretty well so
we do know that basically this is the
only example of locally correctable
codes we could have
so
over f2
if it's known that n needs to be at
least 2 to the omega k which is what the
hadamard code gives
over fp it needs to be where p is the
characteristic of the underlying field
we know that these codes need to be of
size at least p to the k
and this work by the work by barack v
register
showed that over the real numbers they
just can't exist at all
if at the moment we go to three query
codes
what we know much much less of of what
is possible
so the best upper bounds are still are
the read mother codes
where
n
turns out to be 2 to the square root k
so k was the dimension of the set of
points n was the number of points so the
read molecule gives an example of a
three query lcc
where
n is exponential okay n is something
like 2 to the square root k and this is
over again small finite fields
but and over the reals we have
absolutely no examples
of such configuration of configurations
of points where k is growing with n
so of course if you put all points on a
line then it is a three query lcc but
with growing dimension
there are completely no examples
the best low bounds on the other hand
for so what what is the best uh so
we want to rule out constructions of
lccs
for three query lccs the best low bound
we have is actually much worse so over
any field we know that n needs to be at
least k square
so the dimension is that most square
root of n
uh so k is uh
at most square root of n this is the
best which we know which is really far
from the 2 to the square root k bound
and in a very recent new result within
biglesson
which over the real numbers we should
get a very modest improvement over what
the best is known so we knew that n
needs to be at least k squared what we
now show is that n needs to be at least
k to the 2 plus epsilon
so this was some this was the k square
was a kind of barrier to many many proof
techniques
and a lot of proofs seem to
break down at this same
end needs to be at least k square and
over the real numbers we are able to get
a slight improvement we can show n is at
least k to the 2 plus epsilon where
epsilon is something like one over
thousand
and yet so
and that's what i will spend the rest of
the talk discussing some ideas and what
goes into this proof
so this is this is
i think this is a really good
place to
make improvements because
they're very related to all the
sylvester configurations and techniques
and
we understand a lot about it but the
moment we went to higher dimensions
suddenly our understanding seems to be
breaking down
okay so you heard the geometric question
the underlying geometry question for
three query locally correctable codes
again you have n points in some k
dimensional euclidean space
and you know that for every point p i
there is there are many the delta n
think of delta to be something like 1
over 100
so there are delta n disjoint triples
all which span that point
so take another point and then some
other delta n triples which span that
point
so that's how the configuration looks
again the best earlier bounce showed
that if you have such a configuration of
points with this property
then k needs to be smaller than root n n
was the number of points k was a
dimension
and what we show in this work is in fact
k needs to be smaller than
n to the point 499
so we
get a slightly better upper bound on the
dimension
but we don't know
but this bound we have still might be
really far from optimal for all we know
such if any such configuration can only
exist in constant dimensions
when deltas are constant
okay so though we get some improvement
we really still understand very little
about the structure of these points
okay so let me
tell you some ideas in how we prove our
result
so i want to show that k is less than n
to the point four nine nine
as a warm up
let me just first show the y k is
smaller than
root n or root n poly login
so
this so this so
in this warm-up already we'll see some
ideas which will be using the
ingredients in our final proof
so you'll find you have a bunch of
points
and you know that for every point there
are all these disjoint three tuples
spanning it
here is the main idea okay so let's take
this configuration of points and if
possible it's in
pretty high dimensions something more
much more than root n
let's pick some square root n points in
our point set
and map them to zero so we'll find some
linear transformation which puts these
points in the kernel of the
transformation and sends it to zero so
we'll pick square root n points and set
it to zero
so what happens when we do that
you have about
n different
triples these three tuples
and you're going to send square root 10
points to zero
this will tell you
so what is that in with pretty good
probability in one of these triples
you hit two points
in your square from among your square
root one points
because in each triple the probability
that you get two points is one over n
and you have about ten triples
so okay when you set square root n
points to zero the dimension of your
space reduces by square root n and with
the
good probability for many p i's
some triple
in the matching corresponding to that pi
becomes a singleton point
right so two of if you have a triple
where two of the points get set to zero
only one point remains
and that one point so
so that was the one point which remained
there's a triple where two points gets
sent to zero one point remains
and that one point must continue
spanning
p i if the triple spans p i after this
transformation the triple still says
spans p i but two points went to zero
so what happens is p i got identified
with that point the only way one point
spans another they basically the same
point
so p i got identified with it
and you can do this for it and there was
nothing special about that point this is
true for every point in your set there
was this matching
you set when you send square root n
points to zero p i got identified with
some point
so what happens when you do this
basically the set
just shrank by a constant factor
because most points got identified with
some other points so the number of
distinct points just went down
now if you do this entire thing
carefully enough you can see you can see
that you can actually iterate this
process it will shrink by a constant
factor you set another square root n
points it will shrink by another
constant factor and by repeating it log
n times you basically make the whole set
shrink to
only constantly many points
and
hence the original set of points must
have been in square root n log n
dimensions
because you just set square root n
points to zero log n times and the whole
set just vanished and that's basically
the proof of the square root n bound
perhaps one could hope that to improve
this uh argument maybe instead of
setting square root n points to zero you
can do this something more efficiently
instead of random points maybe carefully
cleverly choose points to set to zero
but in general if you know nothing about
the structure of these triples if these
triples are somewhat randomly arranged
then
this kind of random restriction kind of
argument there's not much hope in
improving to
so this is this this analysis is pretty
tight
but what we show in our result the way
we get this improved 0.499
is to show that okay suppose
the dimension is pretty large it's more
than n to the 0.499
then we show that these triples these
different triples which decode every
point they are not actually arbitrarily
arranged there must be a lot of
structure within the triples
so that's the first major component
these triples there's a structure
theorem for these triples
in the second component once you know
that these triples are very structured
now you can perhaps go back and improve
the random restriction argument to get
better bounds and that's what we do so
we'll first show that if the dimension
is high you get a lot of structure and
then exploit the structure to improve
the random restriction argument
so let me tell you what the structure
theorem is
we show that if
the dimension is pretty large
then
these points
cannot be arbitrarily placed these end
points must actually break up into
roughly square root n clusters each of
roughly square root n size
these will actually be square root n
clusters of square root n points and all
these clusters will be roughly
orthogonal to each other
but this geometric placement of the
clusters is not going to know is not
important for us the interesting
property we will also be able to deduce
is that
after you find these clusters square
root n clusters of roughly square root n
points
the triples in your matchings are not
going to have that are not going to be
one point per cluster the triples are
going to be very special for every
triple
two of the points in the triple must be
in the same cluster
so your triples will be either two in
one cluster and one in another cluster
or all three in the same cluster
this is the only
basically the only most of the triples
are going to be of this form
so that's so now and once you have such
a structure for the triples and so these
triples are basically very far from
random if you had a random collection of
triples then you would have triples
coming from different clusters most of
the triples
so this so and once you have the
structure theorem
uh
i'll show how we can get an improved
random restriction first let me tell you
why such a structured theorem might be
possible
and so the main ingredient of our proof
is this very beautiful result from
convex geometry by bath
and this is a very nice statement just
independent of the result i'm talking
about and might be useful elsewhere as
well
and this result says the following
okay suppose you have n points in
k-dimensional euclidean space
and suppose you know that these points
are
nice in the sense that no large subset
of points is in much lower dimension
than the ambient dimension so these
points are somehow nicely distributed
then
you can find you can somehow find the
transformation of for these points you
can find an invertible linear
transformation which you can apply to
these points
so you apply this invertible linear
transformation and then you scale the
points down to becoming unit points okay
so let's do that there exists an
invertible linear transformation m
so that for the new point p i prime
which is m times p i and then normalized
to become unit vectors
these new points are in some sense
isotropic
in this precise sense
look at the new points
then for every other unit vector w if
you look at the sum of inner products of
w with all these pi primes
this quantity is small it's at most n
over k which is roughly n over
0.501
and this is this this bound is what you
would get if these points were all
randomly placed
so in particular one consequence of this
bound is that
with every
you can't have too many for every unit
vector you can't have too many points
correlating with that unit vector
so you can have at most of something
like square root n points having an any
non-trivial correlation
with that unit vector so this this
transformation really spreads out the
points
nicely is there any is it is it any
dependence on k besides the one you
wrote
no
so no so i've hidden what do you mean by
large subset in low dimension
right so and i've put an approximately n
here
so i'm i'm being a little fuzzy about
the constants
for so
if there's no large subset in low
dimensions then you'll win most for most
of the points you might have to prune
the set out by a bit and then you'll
have this property
and by large subset i mean
there's no n over 100 points sitting in
in over a thousand dimensions okay over
a thousand so some there's some play of
constants going on
then you can prune out your set by bit
so that most of your points will then
satisfy this
and then and the o will just have
constants depending on the large subset
low dimension whatever constants you
have there
this is a very nice result
so basically what the consequence is
that no one point will correlate with
too many other points good so you
and the crucial point is this
transformation preserves the property of
being a locally correctable code so if
we had n points which had this three
query lcc property of all these spanning
triples applying a linear transformation
and scaling doesn't affect that property
of uh
being an lcc so we can without loss of
generality kind of assume we are in this
situation where the points are all well
spread out
because if you have a large subset in
low dimensions then you'll win for other
reasons
so let's
we can reduce to the case where all our
points are nicely spread out and no one
point correlates with too many other
points
okay on the other hand if you have a
three query lcc
it's easy to see that you must have many
correlated pairs of points
this is because whenever you have three
points a triple spanning a fourth point
so you have four points which are
linearly dependent
the moment you have four points which
are linearly dependent some pair of
points within those four points will
have non-trivial correlation
so the fact that you are in lcc means
they're many correlated pairs
this result by barth tells you that
these points are all spread out
so the basically the only way to
reconcile both these notions of
points being spread out as well as
having many correlated pairs is
the structure theorem
we mentioned so that it takes some
effort to actually get to the structure
theorem from those two theorems but that
but they are the starting points uh the
fact that you have many correlated pairs
and the result by birth
and if you and taken together we were
able to show such a clustering
roughly square root endpoints in roughly
square root square root n clusters
square root n points each and the
triples every triple intersects a class
some cluster in two points
so that's the
uh
clustering we deduce and now let's see
why given such a clustering
we get the random restriction
so this is basically the last slide of
the argument and then i'll wrap up here
okay so now this
since
the clusters inters these triples
intersect these clusters heavily
a lot of action is happening within the
clusters and not much is happening
between the clusters in some sense
and if you just look at the structure
more carefully
you will see that for every point
you have roughly n triples decoding it
each of these triples must intersect
some cluster
you will it's not hard to deduce that
basically there'll be square root n
triples intersecting cluster one square
root n triples intersecting cluster 2
and so on and so forth
so now what we'll do is instead of
sending square root 10 points at random
to zero from the whole set we'll pick
one of the clusters
and send just fourth root of n points to
zero within that cluster
pick one cluster at random send enter
the one fourth points within that
cluster to zero and then all the same
consequences as before will hold
dimension will reduce by only n to the
one fourth this time
but
if you but if you just look at it
carefully the structure theorem will
just tell you that
this what properties we had before will
continue to hold for every pi
some triple get intersected in two
points p i will get identified with some
point and this size of the set will
shrink by a constant factor
and then you can repeated login times
and you can go down and that's how you
get your improvement
okay so that's so that's basically the
idea of the proof
let me just summarize what we've seen so
we saw
several variations of the sylvester
galley theorem and they were all of the
flavor that if you have many local
linear dependencies then they imply some
global bound on the dimension of the set
of points
and these are very similar to the
freiman ruja kind of theorems in
additive combinatorics where you know
that you have a set of a with many
additive triples within it then
the set of points must be have a lot of
structure or be low dimensional
and in fact a lot of the lower bounds
for two query locally collectible codes
over f2 and fb can be proved using
additive combinatoric techniques over
small fields
so there's a lot of parallels between
both these words and it would be
interesting to see if you can use tools
from here to talk about linear
dependencies instead of additive
dependencies
okay so so and the setting we understand
really very little is the high
dimensional version which is interesting
for lccs
so some of the questions
which i talked about which we don't know
how to answer so these results were very
specific to the real numbers it would be
very interesting to get improved lower
bands for three query lccs over f2
for instance
and this entire random restriction
argument that part of it still works
it's only the barth part which we argue
that this triples must be very
structured which we don't know how to
make work so but perhaps this clustering
is still true over f2
all lccs must be very structured
of course showing much stronger lower
bounds than the ones we show is a very
nice question
it's also very interesting so these were
low bands for three query lccs getting
improved lower bounds for more queries
so many of the ideas again would still
work so all the the everything we talked
about barth and correlations etc still
hold to be true
but in this case the random restriction
part right now is breaking down for more
queries and so we would we need to see
how to get over that
and if you can get better lower bounds
for more queries this is very connected
to the matrix rigidity problem which i
also mentioned
the stable sylvester galley is also a
great question which we have some bounds
but we they're not optimal and it would
be great to improve them
so i'll stop here so thanks
so
what what type of dimension do you think
this structure feel we might still hold
the equals the displacement here and
hold the dimension is close enough
but how do you know when it breaks so
it's a bit fuzzy so we say that it is if
the dimensions at most n to the point
then the kind of structure we get is
that
i said square root n triples with square
dividend clusters but it's
these clusters will have size n to the
half plus minus epsilon the number of
points is also plus minus so they all
they all depend on the gap
from square root n that the dimension
had so it might be able to get it down a
little bit but not nothing significant
it wouldn't be it you won't be able to
make the n to the half into an into the
one fourth
but you can go to end to the one third
maybe
maybe into the one thing you might be
able to come down significantly from end
to the half to end to the one third but
you won't hope to go all it is these
ideas won't get you all the way down to
something
much stronger but you but modest
improvements there's a lot of scope for
and maybe already what we do
might give an improved structure theorem
but then the random restriction would
hurt
so
whatever constants we get kind of
balances out both together we
suffered a little bit in the structured
theorem and got strong random
restriction there we got much better
improved bounce we can only enter the
one fourth loss in the dimension
instead of into the half so the random
restriction part turned out to be very
efficient here but the structure theorem
i was glossy in
but you could you balance it out
good question i don't know
perhaps these are all so strong very
very structured it's just how do you
deduce the structure which is what
it must be structured there are no such
codes
is there a nice way of generating
maybe approximately generating
configurations with prescribed incidence
parameters at random
what do you mean by easiness
we want to have our configuration points
but we just say
such that every for every bond you have
delta and which equals i mean
right so we know actually very few
examples so i said delta the only
examples of delta silver like
configurations we have are basically
these grids or a lot of different lines
with all these points on it we know very
few examples so here we're just capping
the dimension of these points but it
might be true that not only is the
dimension small the set must look like
this very specific set and that we don't
know how to show
okay
thank you very much
you